oh it would help you it feels like chars
are just took a [ __ ] in my mouth hey
what's going on everybody four first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Chiefs tight end
Travis Kelce he's a Pro Bowl tight end
and he also has a new show catching
Kelsey it's on e it premieres October
5th Travis
welcome to the show it is um I don't
necessarily know if it's a pleasure but
we will find out in a little bit do you
know what you're getting yourself into
here
not a big spicy food guy so that's what
I was gonna ask is you playing Kansas
City that's a big barbecue city
sometimes I imagine there's some hot
sauce people there but you're not one of
them I enjoy my barbecue but not so much
the hot sauce are you ready to get it
going let's get this thing going
first one is sriracha Suraj is no big
deal hi why do love wings these reality
dating shows I actually love them I'm
obsessed with them they're my favorite
types of shows the one thing I've
noticed is when you're on one of these
shows and you're competing on one of
these shows you can go one of two routes
you can either just shine and be
somebody that the person wants to date
or you can survive by burying other
people by stabbing them in the back how
do you differentiate somebody who's just
looking out for you from somebody who's
just a snitch the girls will actually
come out and tell you they tell me
they're well I think she's she needs to
just get put on blast because I heard
her saying in the background that you
know she didn't want to be here and that
she was here for her image you know so
girls started to get thrown under the
bus and kind of buried like you said but
at the same time you know it's um it's
all about the certain strategies they've
honestly become the evil sisters and
Cinderella the original sent Cinderella
like the the Whitney Houston but you
have to be careful too cuz sometimes the
person who's stabbing someone in the
back they're actually the person you
need to be watching you know what I mean
they're trying to do a smoke and mirrors
thing where they try to throw him under
the bus but it's actually Kelly who's
the problem you know what I'm saying
Kelly damn it girl so in all these shows
there's always the face-to-face meeting
where you guys meet for the first time
and they always kind of give that person
the stage so that she can do something
to kind of hook Travis in right do you
have any advice for that first meeting
cuz they seem to either go really well
or brick really hard whenever i watch
the we actually have that in the show my
advice to them would just be calm the
heart rate down
don't talk a mile a minute and do
something funny do something funny that
that and something that somebody the
person in front you can relate to and
keep it simple sometimes they get a lot
of moving cards going and then that's
when it's always a disaster are talking
about Kevin the cat
I can't tell that they're getting hotter
that's how the show works know what's
the most obnoxious thing you bought
after signing that 46 million dollar
contract extension obnoxious mmm-hmm you
ever watched Back to the Future yes I'm
a big sneaker guy okay oh you bought the
max not Marty McFly air mags
how much does that put you out seven
five hundred dollars Wow those things
light up and take the attention of the
room every room I go into do you wear
them or do you just put them up in like
a display case or something um they have
their own display case when you buy them
and it's uh it's pretty austere this
pretty sweet box well I I have worn them
out I warm to my first charity event I
went to my first NFL Monday Night
Football game it was kind of like a
coming-out party for me I ended up
having a touchdown about 100 yards was
my best best game at the time it's one
of those things where I where'd the
kicks just because I'm a sneaker head so
I absolutely love going out and showing
that you know why have the sneakers and
not put them on your feet I was just I
would just like to keep them up in the
showcase mmm you got a little sweet and
spicy there mm-hmm mmm is that the let
it marinate a marinade you let high I
think a lot of college standouts they
dream a plane and big markets they dream
a plane in New York they dream plane in
LA but if you really think it through a
place like Kansas City is kind of the
perfect place to play in general I bet
the people are a little bit nicer that
you're recognized locally as kind of a
hero
I'm sure the media scrutiny is just a
drop in the bucket compared to what
you'd go through in New York or
something the best thing about KC is
they're they're die-hard diehard sports
fans every single every single game at
Arrowhead it is rocket that matter of
fact if it's at sorry but mouths
watering um doesn't matter that the deep
inhale was not where I should have gone
with that
those are starting to run nice good luck
this isn't up nice no for definite was
for hmm
so um yeah Arrowhead is uh is awesome
even when I was a rookie and nobody knew
about me I'm still getting recognized
which is crazy knowing that I'm I'm from
Cleveland and I was a Midwest kid how
much I love sports growing up and that's
a sports town it's got a lot of
similarities and especially with the
Royals winning it last year and that's
finally hitting that win streak that
town was rocking right and there was uh
there's no place I'd rather be than the
Kansas City during the season right that
is a that is a tangy delicious hot sauce
that is very nice Thank You Travis
way better than the pain is good fat
kids screaming in your face
so speaking of Kansas City in their
sports fans there's this group of famous
Kansas City sports fans and Rob Riggle
and Jason Vegas and Paul Rudd and they
always seem to be on the scene I have to
think that you've come across these guys
at some point or another does there a
story that stands out to you every
single year they come in and do a
big-time charity event for Kansas City
hospitals and a lot of the the youth and
it's um it's awesome it's called big
slick just being around those guys
knowing that it's for a good cause but
you get to play in the K the Royals
stadium or the Royals arena and it's
like Rob Riggle can't turn it off I mean
he's just he's Rob Riggle and then
wouldn't see what is absolutely stare
what do they talk to you about they talk
football I've seen Paul Rudd in the in
the office or in the in the locker room
after games for the Browns again the
Christmas game he dressed up like Santa
and and did the tomahawk chop and the
bin in the beginning of the game which
was awesome but those guys they loved
getting back to where they're from and
it's showing there
so on their faces man is that a bell
pepper
all right so orange scorpion pepper okay
I could taste it
don't worry bear goddamnit which
Cleveland sports failure are Cleveland
locals when Moses write Aris Bosch
because there's been a lot you have the
earnest Byner fumble you have the
decision obviously you have that Jordan
shot over ello what do you think as
somebody who grew up in Cleveland is the
one Cleveland sports moment failure that
the people in Cleveland are most ashamed
embarrassed by uh we're talking
Cleveland sports no mm-hmm which failure
do you think that Cleveland locals are
most uh are most embarrassed by Jose
Mesa Jose Mesa no I can't say that
because I love the Jose Mesa going into
that game and he wasn't he was a rock
star for us but and we forgive him now
now that that Cleveland has won a
championship when uh the Cleveland
Cavaliers won the finals did you
celebrate cried you did you cried cried
I've been a Cavs fan since Danny Ferry
was running the team well not in the GM
aspect but actually on the floor exactly
it's been awesome to see you know going
from those beautiful black and blue
uniforms to the where they are now and
having the highs and lows of picking
LeBron and LeBron leaving and it's been
like a movie it really has more dramatic
and crazier than movie and then the
believe link comes out right before they
win the championship until they're back
3-1 in the championship it's you're
bringing you're about to bring me the
tears either that or pain 100 is going
to bring you to tears next pain 100% it
is a Kansas City hot sauce mm-hmm how
you feeling at this point in the game my
mouth is on fire I don't know if I'm
even gonna be able to taste this next
one that's a good thing
until I can taste it and it just raise
it to another level
about why I don't know it always puzzles
me but as long as famous people keep
agreeing to do my show
we're gonna keep cycling them through or
just catching fire inhaling smoke you
can always sip the milk you can always
sip the water there's no shame in that I
heard it was frowned upon that's what
you need to tell everybody who tries to
take the milk man no [ __ ] do you have
any say in the scenarios for the dates
are you just as surprised by them as the
ladies room
ah the dates who the dates the dates the
dates were uh did you know about him
beforehand or were you surprised by them
going into him I knew about him um like
I said a lot of it a lot of it some what
you would see in the off season of a guy
trying to make money off the field and
do make appearances Wow and you should
have brought him to our show yeah no
right had these ladies call the press
run Travis what the [ __ ] is this how
would you plan the perfect first date in
your hometown of Cleveland is it the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and the
Christmas Story Museum are you going
down a different road I like I like we
were going with that - very very icon
rate iconic places to go and Cleveland
um take them to the pier there's always
a go - um I can't even think about
Cleveland right now um yeah the take it
take it take her to the pier better see
those beautiful waves coming in
you know there's no surf like Cleveland
Lake Erie's got it like that best
beaches and the best beaches in the
state sorry my sweating don't apologize
for it everybody does just be careful
around your eyes God thank you that you
want us to slow down a little bit now do
you quit I love it
let's get to [ __ ] mmm
so hard that's disgusting mm-hmm why why
I remember poor auntie I know in every
interview that you do they probably try
to like make you dance in every single
one I'm sure that they do that and I
know that you're a nice guy you probably
do it and I bet it's reluctantly so I'm
not gonna ask you to dance but I do have
a dance question because I saw you at
this professional bull riding event you
got in a dance-off I hope this guy skim
milk turn you guys were competing for a
belt buckle and skim milk won but
anybody who watches that clip knows that
fundamentally you're a better dancer did
you feel robbed no no I didn't I didn't
feel robbed at all I just left the most
terrible taste I can't barely hear talk
right now I don't want to touch my lips
don't worry that's a touch stay away but
I do have to respect I've gone from milk
a couple times that is it would help you
it
I'm getting dizzy as all hell right now
skim milk was solid he was uh he went
all out and that's what I respected guys
like it's got good guns
oh yeah oh yeah got it you got to get
into it man if you don't get into you're
just are you feeling it literally says
use at your own risk
on the [ __ ] bottle yep
you know everybody always asked football
players about the craziest visiting
stadiums to play in and which fans are
the wildest the most intimidating right
but sometimes I think about the other
way which visiting stadium would you say
has the most chill laid-back and polite
fans are you talking about what which
NFL fan base has fans that are just kind
of chill they're not as in-your-face
they're not screaming at you a little
bit more polite uh San Diego San Diego
has played fans today or real nice
people man Travis we are now on wing ten
you have to take a sip of water or a sip
of milk you're not a hot sauce guy
you're sweating profusely in the face so
I know you're really going through it
okay breathe so for this last one it's
tradition around here that we dab the
last one you don't have to if you don't
want to but I would say you have come
this far so you just do a little drop
you got to be careful because sometimes
we'll avalanche give it a fake oh I want
to go to the hospital after this
people stomach is an active very nice
feeling with shotgun epitope is my life
I love it man all right Travis Kelce 10
wings no sips of milk
no sips of water all the way to Blair's
Megadeth sauce absolutely incredible tap
this wing will eat it and then cheers
brother
Cheers all right
so my only real professional goal is I
want a menu item named after me I want a
sandwich
I want the spicy Shawn Cuban sandwich on
a menu somewhere
are you a big enough deal where you have
a menu item yet
yes you do okay what's it called what is
it where is it served I need to know
everything about the Travis Kelce food
item the Kelsey Cincinnati Reuben even
though the Reuben sandwiches are kind of
a cleveland-based deal it's in Kansas
cities is that McFadden's oh my god and
uh yeah it's about all I got for you man
it out comes with some good talk
comes with chips and a drink has some
garlic fries Parviz garlic fries they
had to help him oh come on where's our
garlic tots how would you describe the
taste ah what how would you do the item
of your sandwich
here's the lease delicious for the
sauerkraut is not too much is not too
light
we're just perfect so just like the
Blair's Megadeath sauce yes perfect
people amazing Travis you made it
through with no water no milk let the
record show absolutely amazing
Travis the floor is yours this camera
that camera let the people know what you
got going on in your life
uh-huh right now I'm in pain guys it's a
charge cows in here um feeling real
woozy ah it's car what brother your show
or something
Oh show she'll attract caching Kelsey
premieres on the E and 9 o'clock Eastern
October 5th
this this upcoming season you're amused
by this
[Music]